joining me now is ari fleischer former
white house press secretary current fox
news contributor and author of the new
book suppression deception snobbery
and bias
ari um i have to say um
if this is all they got republicans have
to feel pretty good tonight i mean jb
pritzker
what
yeah it's been a long time laura since
the democrats reached down to the ranks
of their governors for a candidate you
have to go back to 1996 bill clinton was
the last governor who became the
democratic nominee they liked senators
in 2000 2004 2008 2012 16 20 they all
nominated senators or former senators
but let me remind you in the 2019 2020
cycle
28 democrats ran for president in 2019
and 20. four of them were governors or
former governors so when joe biden
announces he's not running which he will
do after the midterm election and into
early 2023
it will be a donny brooke a free-for-all
every democrat will jump into the water
governors senators and dog catchers one
and all
well ari they're already getting ready
because of course the democrats and the
media are all
you know setting setting upon biden for
his age for his lack of mental acuity
it's now it's it's not a secret anymore
everybody's kind of talking about it
but in illinois i just want to focus on
pritzker for a moment because you have
these major
companies
that are just deciding to leave illinois
because of the high tax high regulation
dangerous crime
in the city of chicago obviously we have
citadel ken griffin's company leaving
illinois that was a huge loss he's going
to miami we have caterpillar leaving we
have boeing leaving
i mean these are these are blue chip
companies saying
we like to stay we love illinois but
under this leadership we're out how does
jb pritzker get on that list
you know and that's going to be the
problem for every one of these
democratic governors whether it's new
york new jersey california illinois
those states are all losing populations
mostly to red states for the logical
reasons that you just cited quality of
life issues crime issues economic issues
and it's wonderful i'm in chicago right
now laura and it's interesting to note
the major businesses that are pulling
chalks and getting out of here and
they're doing it because they're fed up
they're doing it because the state just
has one answer to everything and that's
to raise taxes and make life more
difficult so they're now they're voting
with their corporate headquarters will
the people start to see it will it
change the reactions in the states i
don't know about that because the
majorities are so hugely democratic in
california illinois and new york but it
really does make it hard to be a
governor and become a president as a
sitting democratic governor all right
they're going to lose hundreds of
millions of dollars in tax revenue when
these companies leave which they already
said they're leaving the numbers for
biden um are so bad i mean every time
you come on we say he's reached a new
low well he reached another new low
today
33 percent in one poll 33 36 and another
among the suburban voters
he has an approval of 37 percent among
non-white 43 percent uh approved 49
disapprove
i mean ari this is
it's not getting any better the more
they put joe biden out the worse he
seems to do final thoughts and he's
about to turn 80 years old and it shows
every time joe biden is seen walking
i think he loses a vote people look at
him and they just go he doesn't have
what it takes the stamina the energy the
strength to be present this all adds up
and it's why the democrats are in such
trouble oh ari 80 is the new 40 isn't it
kind of
good to see you all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else